[Music]
all right thank everyone for attending
this webinar and for the kind intro this
is gonna be our agenda today as you can
see we're gonna start slow with you know
just getting a view of how how to use
extensions from sparkley are and we're
gonna work our way out up to
understanding how to build extensions
for spark using sparkly are definitely
if you are a new user you should be able
to get still a lot of value out of this
webinar and if you're an advanced user
I'm hoping that this gives you the extra
information you need to get your
packages and extensions going so with
that let's start first of all with the
overview and first of all I want to give
you no quick reference to our first
webinar Edgar who also works at our
studio presented this webinar and if you
haven't gone through the first webinar I
highly encourage you to take a quick
look at that it will walk walk you
through out the true out understanding
what sparkly re is what's parties and
what what what can you do with these two
systems together so definitely
definitely take a look at that but just
for those for those of you that might
have started cold or that are taking a
look at this first webinar what I want
to highlight for that first webinar is
that spark it's a cluster computing
engine by itself it does not provide
storage but you can you can use several
storage providers through Apache spark
wherever your big data may may lead and
as a quick intro to sparkly are sparkly
are is an our package is sparkly our to
interface into Apache spark from our
think about as sparkly are as any other
package that lives in cran which is our
package repository for our packages and
you can make use of sparkly art to
interoperate with spark so that's does
like
really high-level overview of what
sparkly R is and what at spark Apaches
parties
definitely each of them have different
functionality for instance when you look
at art you can see things like
definitely well we mentioned that is a
glossary computing engine it's also a
sequel interface it supports in-memory
processing an extensible API machine
learning graph processing streaming and
when you look at sparkly RS Berkeley air
allows you to make use of all these
functionality and there's there's few
there's there's some functionality that
is enabled by default in sparkly R for
instance you can make use of the deep
layer backend machine learning
functionality extensions and in the
sparkly ro 6 release also use
distributed these relate computations in
R however there's this question of well
what do I do if for some reason I need
either more functionality in spark or
more functionality in sparkly R that is
is not a functionality that is available
by default in the in the package or in
spark and that's that's what this
webinar is about we're gonna understand
where where to start by extending
functionality and using functionality
that others have extended in sparkly R
and we're gonna learn how to extend the
functionality that both spark and
sparkly r provides you can think of
these as a lifecycle of kind of like
developing and extension to sparkly are
the first thing that you would want to
use is take a look at the extensions
that are already available in sparkly R
so for instance on the top right we have
an example where we're loading the are
sparkling library that will allow you to
connect to h2o
one way of using extensions in sparkly R
is simply by using other packages that
provide support for sparkly our
extensions and it's very easy to use
we're gonna go into that in detail but
it's good to know that that's the first
step where you want to start by looking
at new functionality as part that is not
called too sparkly are the next step is
when you when you find yourself in a
situation when there's not when you
don't find an extension already
available for sparkly are what you can
do is use our code
to extend the functionality in sparkly
are or use additional functionality from
spark and a spark extension directly
using our code we're gonna we're gonna
cover this in detail but it's good to
know that there's there's there's a way
for you to use additional functionality
using only our code and for those of you
that are doing more advanced
explorations and need more advanced
features they the next step would be to
actually use full functionality of Scala
code Scala Scala is the programming
language that was used to implement
Apache spark so by combining both R and
Scala code you definitely have access to
hundred percent of the functionality
available on the spark ecosystem so it's
both a pretty powerful tool and but also
it usually requires additional
understanding of spark and api's and
things like this this this stepped using
Scala code is somewhat optional you can
you can actually move to the next step
from using our code directly to creating
our packages without really needing
Scala code but worth mentioning that
once once you have a set of
functionality that is worth sharing
either with your colleagues in your
internal organization or broadly with a
our community what you want to do is
consider creating in our package so in
the same way that you would consider
creating on our package for a
functionality that goes into cran or
that you would distribute with your
colleagues as a zip file or in our you
know local crown repo you can do the
same with sparkly R and sparkle our
packages all right so these discovers a
brief overview of what we're going to
talk about these during the webinar
we're gonna get started with how to use
extensions with sparkly are so
extensions the first the first step in
building an extension that you want to
consider is to go to spark our studio
calm and under extensions
you should be able to find a list of
extensions that are have been currently
developed by the community around
sparkly are we try to keep this list as
updated as possible and but definitely
let us know if for some reason you find
an extension that is not listed here in
general you want to take a quick look at
the what are they what the extensions
provide and consider whether this is an
extension that is worth using on on your
own on your end for this particular
webinar we're gonna take a look at three
of the extensions that are already
available we're gonna take a look at
part sass 7b dot which is an extension
to read SAS data in parallel into Apache
spark we're also going to look at the
are sparkling extension which was
developed by the H but h2o which
provides machine learning algorithms on
Apache spark using their cluster engine
and we're gonna take a look at spark
sparkly graphs which is a pretty recent
addition to the sparkly Oracle system
which provides support for graph frames
graph frames is an interesting project
because it enables the use of graphics
within spark data frames so all of them
are pretty interesting where let's gonna
switch to ours to you and we're gonna
see them looking in second alright so
you should be seeing notebook by the way
I'm gonna make this notebook available
it's gonna be posted on the on the
webinar materials so you should be able
to also try these yourself in general
what you wanna do is basically just open
up open the file and then reopen it in
in our studio once once you have the
notebook so taking a look at the three
extensions that we're gonna covering
today to save us some time what we're
gonna do for this demo is we're gonna
load the tree extensions at the same
time and this is obviously kind of like
something that you might need in some in
says right like sometimes you might want
to work with only one extension but it's
also often the case that you might want
to work with many of them so you can do
that by loading the libraries and first
of all installing them some of them the
first two are already on cron the
sparkly graph will be on crime probably
pretty soon so once installed what you
want to do is load the libraries load
sparkly R and followed by connecting to
sparkly R this in the same way that you
would usually connect you what is
happening in the background is basically
when SPARC is establishing the
connection when a sparkly are
establishing the connection is asking
each of the libraries what dependencies
do they need in order to function
properly on SPARC and it's loading them
into your cluster this means that this
particular approach requires internet
connectivity
good to know in case you you don't then
you would there's there's guys that we
have that can help you also set up a
cluster one and you don't have internet
connectivity first extension that we're
gonna take a look at its the SAS
extension and what we're doing here is
well first of all is the first time that
we execute a query on sparkly R so it's
basically initializing still some of the
SPARC components this first time but
then we're reading a SAS file into
Apache spark again like if we were to
read securities it would be pretty fast
and yeah it's honestly it's pretty
pretty straightforward and it's
basically what you would expect on spark
on this park we have many many several
functions that follow the same pattern
to read from different data sources CSB
Jason JDBC pirkei etc and as you can see
the spark read SAS does not come from
sparkly R but rather comes from a a
community package which is it's great so
pretty straightforward
sparkly R and the community that
developed this package already do the
heavy lifting to get you up up and
running here and in a similar way the
next the next example that we're going
to try out is
using h2o with our sparkling throughout
our sparkling which is the package that
provides from this functionality in
sparkly our to get us started we're
gonna load the plier and copy some data
you can see that data has loaded and you
can we can take a quick peek just the
cars table that we're all familiar with
and the interesting thing here is even
though we're we haven't we haven't done
much our code ourselves a lot of things
have happened on the back end in spark
by running h2o flow for these particular
extensions what we're gonna launch is
the h h2 o's cluster interface and
what's happening on the recover sees h2o
is initializing and then very briefly
we're gonna get access to h2 O's
interface this this application is
running on Apache spark and provides a
lot of functionality that would require
probably a different webinar on this
topic just to to explain but for those
of you that are interesting and using
h2o it's in our spark it's a great way
to get started I'm not gonna get into
many details on how to use h2o but it's
good to know that the extension exists
and we're gonna run a very simple case
use case so in this case what we want to
do is we want to convert the spark data
frame that we have into something that
h2o understands so we're gonna run as
h2o data frame and followed by running a
simple
GLM model so let's just run these two
together and again it finished executing
and then what we can do here is take a
look at the results of these GL and
model run not over Emily but rather over
h2s computing platform running on spark
this is this is the output of our model
it probably matches closely what you
would expect from GLM in our and h2o
sorry and spark but it comes with
different set of
Crowder's and variables that depending
on the use case that you're following
too might make sense to consider using
h2o versus other technologies the next
the next station that we're gonna cover
briefly again is the sparkly graph
extension which allow us to make use of
graphics functionality we're gonna start
by first again copying data set for
those of you that are curious about
these data set is maybe not as
well-known as the two previous ones but
it's basically it's it's it's it's it's
graph like already by itself it's it's a
dataset that contains friendships among
high school boys dating 1957 and 1958
but it's one of these data sets that
we've we've we've used as samples on
other craft packages on their community
so we've loaded that and something
something that we need to know about
this extension is that you need to
provide to two data frames for the
extension one contains the vertices and
the other one contains edges these data
set by itself contains the data mixed
together so actually we can take a quick
look just to see how it looks like but
basically it comes with an identifier of
that particular person and their
friendship relationship over over the
period of two years
so we're basically gonna split these
into table of vertices and a table of
edges and once once we have them in this
format we can run PageRank if if you
want to take a closer look at what
functionality is supported in each of
the packages there's there's multiple
ways of doing it one of the ones that I
personally like is just simply typing
the package and then just looking at the
functions with without a complete in
this case as for this webinar we're only
gonna look over the PageRank algorithm
but but there are a few others that you
might be interested in and same
same for h2o there's definitely several
functionality that it's worth worth
exploring exploring and sorry for h2o
also you will have to make use of the
h2o library so definitely a lot of lots
of functionality to cover in just one
webinar but it's great a start so let's
just run PageRank and kind of like
validate that we're we're getting these
functionality out of the package and
yeah that's that's kind of like covers
our tree extensions if you want to take
a look at all our full list what I would
recommend is going too far toward our
studio calm and you should be able to
identify them on their extensions
definitely if you're developing one and
it happens not to be here let us let us
know all right so
we covered we covered three of the
extensions if if you really want to get
your hands into this notebook you can go
to our pops my my username and then
sparkley our extensions we're in our
2017 but we're also going to post these
contents on our on our webinar page so
so so next step in our kind of like life
cycle that we we we discuss at the very
beginning so what happens when you don't
find functionality that is available as
I'm sparkly our extension the first the
first you know website that I would
recommend you taking a look at it's
called
smart packages org
let's take you were to take a look at
this website you're gonna see that this
is a repository of packages that have
been developed on this part by the spark
community completely unrelated which
sparkley are but that have made that
have been made available to enhance
spark functionality you can see that
there's different categories for
instance there is a category on there
data sources that basically allows a
spark to connect to multiple order
storage providers and technologies data
sources happens to be one of the easiest
extensions to develop withing sparkley
are and we're going to take a look at
these on the right side so the code that
we have on the right side is doing
something a little bit more advanced
than what we saw on on the previews on
the previous topic we're loading sparkly
R and then we're creating a
configuration object by calling the
spark config and then we're specifying
this configuration parameter called
default packages as you can see default
packages is pointing to this part
Cassandra connector which happens to be
an extension listed on spark packages so
basically by using the lines lines four
to seven on this code snippet and
including the correct dependency you can
you
load any of the spark packages available
on this far community for this
particular extension extension you can
may make use of a generic function that
we've implemented on sparkly arrow six
called spark underscore read underscore
source and what that enables you is
basically use any data source extension
directly from our code so this is a very
very easy way to extend spark
functionality in terms of connecting to
multiple data sources that you can take
advantage of is if that's what what
you're the function editor you're
missing in your day-to-day analysis now
what happens when you want to do more
advanced things that you know might not
be covered by a generic sparkley our
function and the example that I want to
cover today and go over is mostly just
as an educational example what what
would it would take us to get started
with spark streaming if we really didn't
have much you know much but they what
the functionality that we currently
support in sparkly R so let's take a
look at these well first first of all
there's there's a well documented site
on the spark website for performing
string programming streaming programming
in in spark that's that's a great place
to get us get us started so I'm gonna
open that website and kind of like we
just walk you through what what what a
day today in developing extensions
usually looks like on this particle
system so regardless of the topic
usually what you find yourself looking
at is posed based on most likely Scala
code in which someone has made available
new functionality so in this case we're
taking a look at spark streaming and you
can see that in this case we have
section with Scala code and this color
code it's it's doing a couple
interesting things is for instance
creating a streaming context out of the
current configuration and is giving
giving it ad duration so
once once you have like a good sense of
how this is being developed in in Scala
you can start thinking in terms of how
to develop these in our and that's
that's what we're gonna do for the
second part of our demonstration we're
back in our in our studio and we're
taking a look at at our notebook and
you're going to use your you should be
able to see here that I've copy pasted
basically that fragment of Scala code
that we've seen from this or extreme ink
documentation the interesting thing here
I'll do this a little bit bigger for
those of you knew that
what appreciate is and what you can see
here is that we have Scala code but what
we really want to do is call our code to
perform that functionality and in this
case we're we're gonna try to get just
the bare bare bare bone basics of SPARC
streaming working with to true sparkly
are with these with with the
functionality that's part we are
provides there are three functions that
you should be aware of while working
with our code and this is this is
functionality in sparkly are the first
one is it's called invoke this this
function will allow you to call methods
from an Scala object there's one
function called invoke static and this
one will help you call static methods in
Scala and there's also invoking you
which this function will help you call
new or create new objects in Scala so so
these three functions are are the core
principles that you would use while use
running Scala code from our I'm gonna
delete them since I already have some
code ready for you here and what you can
see here is that in order to match this
statement in Scala what we want to do is
a call
invoke new mostly because we're creating
a new streaming object so we're gonna do
that and invoke new requires the spark
connection that you're already familiar
with and then it takes classname a fully
qualified class name or so what you want
to do here is make sure that even though
in this case streaming context it's the
name of the class this color code
imported the namespace with the fully
qualified version of it and that's what
you want to use so in this case we're
gonna run the fully qualified name for
this class we're gonna pass this this
part this spark context and then there's
another object that this method requires
which is the duration which you want
this trimming to happened the batch size
for this for this streaming to happen in
their in their in their sample they're
setting it to one second it's actually
easier to demonstrate see if we set up
to something longer like 10 seconds and
what we want to do in order to create
this object is we can call invoke new
over the duration object and pass 10
seconds or ten thousand milliseconds so
let's run that one as a start
nothing interesting so far but well I
mean it's interesting that we do have a
streaming streaming context right so
next step that you would see on their
documentation is that they will create a
socket stream and while we're talking
while we're doing streaming programming
in in spark one of the basic
demonstrations of its use is basically
opening a socket which is a it's just a
connection back into spark where we can
send comments directly into spark rather
than rather than making spark fetching
them so we're gonna do that as you can
see here in this case in their
documentation they're calling they're
calling a method over this streaming
context objects that we that we created
so in order to do that what we're gonna
use is they invoke function over the
streaming context so same thing we are
calling invoke over streaming function
and then we're calling the method which
is named socket X
stream and we're gonna pass two
parameters one is localhost which is
where this socket is going to be
expecting the connections to be coming
from and then the port number that's
that's about it one thing to consider
here is that invoke methods do require
all parameters to be explicitly passed
and you'll see in the def you were to
look at the definition of this method
which I'm gonna provide at the end of
these this webinar you would see that it
actually takes one more parameter
without default values so we're
explicitly creating a one object which
is the storage level and we're setting
it to memory and disk okay this this has
run the next the next step is a
simplified version of what you would see
on the post what we're gonna do in this
particular example is we just want to
get the count of words that are coming
into our spark stream and printing the
count very simple example just gonna run
it hopefully your this this syntax is
starting to look familiar in this case
we're using dave migrator pipe that is
posed used in the plier and then
migrator package itself you don't need
to use the migrator pipe if you don't
like if you don't like using them you
can also get the return value and pass
it pipe it back to the next one so
that's totally up to you in general we
like a lot these syntax even while using
spark invoke it sparkly or invoke
commands so last but not least what
we're gonna do is we are gonna start the
stream and we're gonna take a quick look
at what's going on on this arc UI so as
you can see here in this part you i we
have streaming job running and you
you'll see the progress as we as we send
things into this job also once you
create this part extreme in context you
get additional functionality with from
spark etc but just focusing on kind of
like these webinar which is about
extending spark we are
let's let's just do a quick run of how
these would look and for this I'm gonna
use the terminal feature which is fully
available on our Studio 1.1 which is
currently on preview so think about
these tabs just that terminal that you
would that you would use on on outside
our studio it's a great feature right I
really do love it so what we're doing
here is we're gonna connect to the spark
stream on the port that we specify start
to be connected at and we're just gonna
send some data let's just send a PC so
that's three words and what's happening
on the recovers is Sparky's getting this
information and printing the line count
of of the output so let's just try to
take a quick look there's gonna be a lot
of noise here but what we can see in the
in the log is that you know spark
streaming is doing what we would expect
is basically printing the number of
words that we sent through the stream
and again this webinar is not really
about spark streaming but I thought it
would be great to give it a shot and see
how far we can get with simple sparking
bugs to get some spark streaming going
on this webinar so I'm gonna disconnect
from here and we're gonna talk about one
more concept in our webinar so it so far
it has been great that we've you know
that we've used only our code to get the
basics of spark streaming working
however there's gonna be more advanced
scenarios that you want to address and
for instance in this particular case you
know like there's things there's
additional things that are that that
their blog post is doing like creating
flat map map out of out of splitting the
words so rudder rudder rudder done only
counting the words what they're doing is
they're splitting each word and then
counting the words per line and you can
look throughout the post post and you're
gonna find that there's more advanced
functionality that you would want to use
in scala directly
and for that that kind of cases what I
want to get back to is to our
presentation and talk about how do well
first of all how do how to map data
types between our and Scala even while
you're using arc our code and then we're
going to take a look at how to use Scala
code directly in our package this is a
table that I recommend taking a look
look at if you're once once you start
doing using making use of invoke and
related functions you can take a look at
this table directly in our extensions
page page by going under data types
basically what this table is explaining
is how to map data types from R into
Scala so I mean some things are pretty
obvious right like if you want to pass
an integer to Scala well that's just an
integer if you want to pass a character
well that just becomes the string in
Scala but a couple other ones could be a
little bit less intuitive so for
instance a list in a listing sparkly R
becomes an array in Scala and thinks if
you had to map if you had to create
create a map or you sub function that
uses a map you will want to use an
environment that from from our they they
catch-all object that you would use
while using sparkly our extensions is
called a J object and this is a short
short name for Java object is basically
a reference to an object so whenever
whenever there is an object that you
need to pass in the same way that we did
with a duration object you would want to
create a J object and then pass it
directly to Scala as an object but
definitely definitely once you start
getting immersed into into this topic
worth taking a look at this table
especially to help you troubleshoot
calls when when you can find the right
method to call
so last last you know section on how to
develop code in sparkly are and what
we're gonna cover here is just briefly
how do how to create scala how do you
Scala code from within from within
sparkly are and how to package it
together one of the best ways to get
started with writing Scala code from R
is there's there's two ways but let's
take a look let's take a look at first
that a project called spark hello it
currently runs under my repo mostly
because it's a very simple project
doesn't have a lot of you know
interesting things in it except except
that it showcases how to use Scala code
from within within within sparkly R and
to give you an overview of what what's
your goal when using while using Scala
code in in sparkly are basically what
this process is gonna trigger by using a
function called compiled package jars
it's gonna enable to compile the Scala
code that you have on your package into
jars that are version dependent and
become part of your package that that
sparkly R would use during connection
so basically Scala code runs on the JVM
once compiled and it's packages jar
files this is this is pretty pretty
technical for those for those that view
but that might not be familiar with Java
programming but it's honestly pretty
straightforward it's basically you can
think of this jar as a zip file that
contains compiled code from from Scala
and sparkly R does all the magic by
calling compiled packaged jars all you
need to worry about is creating the
Scala code that you want to use to
extend sparkly are now to make your life
easier what I'm gonna briefly cover is
how to create these kind of packages so
[Music]
there's there's
two ways of creating or there's there's
two motivations for creating in our
package I believe on the sparkly our
ecosystem one is to share it with your
colleagues and your organization and the
other one is to share it with cran you
could argue that there's a third third
argument for creating and sparkly our
package which is to for keeping your
code structured
well while you're developing
functionality but definitely the first
you make sense I'm gonna I'm gonna cover
that while while we talk about running
Scala code because there's a really nice
way for you to get started in creating
sparkly are extensions
well while you can create on sparkly our
extension since version o for what I'm
gonna show you is a little feature that
we have under development on the sparkly
our version so by this means that you
would want to install this the
development version of sparkly are by
running dev tools installed github and
what's what what what this is going to
give you is gonna give you a new project
type in inside hours to you that can get
you up and running with your sparkly our
extension and spark code really fast so
let's let's take a look at that and talk
also about compiling Scala code well
while we do this alright so as you can
see first of all I want to make sure
that everyone is aware that we're using
sparkly r 0.7 own 9000 which is an on
unreleased version of sparkly our our
latest version of spark of berkeley our
is 0.6 that you would find in crime so
in order to get this functionality you
would have to install the new the latest
version of development of sparkly our
and then you can go and say file new
project you don't need to save these and
we're going to create a new directory
and if you scroll all the way to the
bottom you're gonna see that there's a
new our package using sparkly our entry
and that's that's the one you want and
then you want to give it just package
name the same way that you would give a
package name when you create
our package so I'm gonna just call this
one
sparkly our test one and that's pretty
much it
what you would get out of these once you
create the package is we're gonna give
you basically a template with the things
that you want to use when you create and
sparkly our extension well first of all
we're giving you are with me we're
giving you a readme file with some
instructions on how to get and compiled
Scala code into first part clear
extensions or use are they our package
itself so we're just gonna follow the
instructions here but before doing that
I want to show you that there's two
components on a sparkly are extension
the first one is they are code and these
are code can be anything you would use
an app on a on a use on it on our
extension right so you know it just
happens it's there's really nothing
really particular about you know they
are code that that we have on their
files except that at times you would
want to use sparkly R as your main
library for building this extension and
spark related functionality so in this
case what we're doing in this this
function called sparkly are just one
underscore hello is calling a spark
function running sorry its color
function running in spark and the class
name is called sparkly art test1dot main
which happens to be the class that we've
pre created for you and the method that
we're calling is called hello so if we
know that we're switching into this
color class you can see that there is
like a very very small amount of Scala
code here that basically what it's doing
is saying hey whenever you call me
return hello world from Scala and that's
pretty much it if you had to use for
instance advanced spark string or why
not
you would include here you would add
important or directives and you would
you would use all the functionality that
you would expect from from from running
scholar
code right and in spark but let's let's
just complete these this the steps in
the readme file so first of all let's
build a package so I'm hitting build you
just finished building and then what we
want to run is we want to build a jars
so as you can see here on the right side
we only have the Java in our directory
but once once we run sparkly our
compiled jars it's basically getting
this color code out of your package and
creating the correct set of jars that
you would your extension would need and
again this is mostly transparent to you
but you definitely want to at least be
aware of these so here they are and then
we want to reveal to make sure that
these jars become part of our package
and next step is basically that's that's
pretty much it we're done building the
extension now we're gonna use it we're
gonna include our library sparkly our
test one we're gonna include a sparkly R
and we're gonna connect and we're gonna
run our helper function and that's
that's pretty much it honestly you know
like most of the work you find yourself
spending you know either working with
spark or Scala from sparkly R will just
get you get up and running and execute
your Scala code which is something
interesting to notice is that you know a
lot of the extension and a lot of the
functionality that we've developed and
sparkly R we've actually started it as
extensions and then we integrate about
it into a sparkly are just mostly
because it's it's it's it's it's really
a great framework to get you started and
componentize your functionality alright
so that covers our packages i closing
before we get into questions i just want
to give you a few resources that you
probably will want to keep in mind while
you're developing extensions the first
one is the spark guitar studio.com
website the extensions section would be
a great place to start but also just to
learn about more about spark our studio
and sparkly are the resources are gonna
be for that i cover on this webinar are
gonna be posted under our webinars
website that would be under our
studio.com resources webinars find this
webinar and in a couple days you should
have
access to this presentation and also
their notebook that we use if you hit
any issues please follow us on
github.com our Studios sparkly our we
encourage people to try first Stack
Overflow to answer generic questions but
if if you really stuck with something or
if you have a something that looks like
an sparkly our issue feel free to open
open it there and we'll take a look at
it and finally mostly a resource
particular to these presentation is the
spar documentation and mostly you you
will find yourself working a lot with
this color API if you decide if you
choose to use Scala code to create your
sparkly or extension so definitely worth
look at this at this website and that's
pretty much it I'm gonna switch back to
questions and yeah I see see three
questions here let's see so first
question in the Scala code for streaming
there are defaults do these defaults
need to be specified in the our code or
is this being demonstrated demonstrate
us the best practice so today it's it
needs to be specified right it's not
it's not a demonstration it's one one of
the feet it's it's it just needs to be
explicitly listed in in your sparkly our
code so definitely one when you're
dealing with defaults it's really handy
to have this part documentation at hand
while grading you know extensions and
mostly because you can you can have like
a full sense of how how the method is
defined so yes take a look take a look
at the at the defaults and pass them
explicitly honestly I realize that this
could be a little bit it could be
annoying at times so what I'm gonna do
after this webinar is gonna I'm gonna
open a github issue to make sure that we
track this feature request I think it
would be great if we could just call it
invoke without passing the defaults and
remove some of the burden out of the
package builders
like myself from having to figure out
what the default is but yeah as of today
you need to specify the default it's
honestly not that bad and at times it's
also a bit of a good practice to pass
them pass it but yes it's something that
you need to specify hi thanks looks
really powerful is there a way for
reading binary files and thinking of
images too sparkly are what I need to
create an extension ah yes so you would
have to create an extension sparkly R
doesn't come with support for loading
images by default you know you can work
around a few ways you know doing couple
hockey hockey things but you don't want
to do that so I think what you want to
look into is using an extension
definitely it's not an extension that
I've seen anyone developing on the
sparkly our ecosystem I think it would
be pretty pretty great especially now
with topics like deep learning and image
classification would be would be
something like definitely worth worth
taking a look at first my you know my
initial recommendation would be to first
take a look at what house park supports
images in their you know in their inner
framework and I'm hopeful that actually
we could follow a lot of those practices
even by only using our code as you can
see as you could see like we were able
to get to get some of the basic of spark
streaming working and connecting to data
sources is also pretty easy from from
our code but yeah definitely take a look
at what what's part provides if you want
to feel free to open a github issue on
the sparkly re plus a question and I'll
be happy to take a look I think it's a
really interesting topic and worth worth
considering building something around
this for for processing images on spark
we are and I have one we have one last
question perhaps I missed it but if I
have a jar or a set of jars are those
jars included in the insta
yeah that's that's a great great
question so the answer is yes we include
those jars in your package so if you
were to publish this into crime or share
it with your colleagues
by default we we save those jars in the
insta-bed folder which means that
they're gonna become available when you
install your package and when when you
when you connect from true spark
connecting using sparkly are extending a
bit on your question there there there
are there order more advanced use cases
where you would want to include your own
jars so suppose that either your company
or or you as a data scientist find that
there's a really interesting library
greetin in Java or Scala and is provided
as a jar one of the things that you
could also use with sparkly are and
spark compile would be to include these
custom jar in the instance jar in Java
directory and once your package compiles
you would be able to make use of these
functionality within a spark so yeah
definitely
definitely good to know that you know
these jars can actually be included we
include them by default and you can also
include additional jars in in the in the
package okay we have a few other
questions coming so feel free to post
them we have we still have an extra five
minutes so we can cover as many as
possible let's see so the question is
how would you manage conflicting jar
versions between different extensions
yeah this Oh completing your versions
between different extensions this is
this is an actual tough one so so let me
just give you some background so first
of all when we think of conflicting
versions the way that we solve this
problem for sparkly R was by versioning
or jars so we basically we basically add
support for multiple we compile multiple
versions that you can actually see on on
our own on our studio on the instance
Java folder if you were to have
conflicting Java versions between
extensions I honestly
I think that would I think honestly you
know definitely it's something that we
haven't hit mostly because a lot of the
extensions you spark resources and
there's no need to add additional jars
some of the extensions to use jars but
it's it's a bit of a corner case that we
haven't even hit so far if obviously one
one way of one way of unblocking
yourself would be to load one extension
at a time and honestly you know this
this is a bit of a problem that we would
hit on the spark ecosystem so I I think
my answer would be try not to do it and
avoid it if if you're using spark
specific spark versions to build your
jars that we and that's the way that we
recommend you do it with sparkly are we
shouldn't hit these this issue for the
most part however there's there could be
definitely cases where you hit these
that's it I'm I'm not I'm not that sure
that they would be that different from
submitting jars to spark so I I think we
would have to take a broader step back
and figure out how to deal with these on
the spark community I think for most
cases people use spark in per
application and you know like you can
you can partition your analyses over you
know the a functionality that you use on
your spark running application we didn't
affect order running applications on
spark so in that way they're continent
component ties but yeah if I use her
yourself you have to two extensions that
you want to use and you both submit and
submit them to spark I think this is a
bit of an not you know a broader problem
in the spark community that we have to
to address so let us know if you're
hearing this obviously happy to help but
it does feel a little bit of a of a
corner corner case and last question
oh not no question but I've interested
to see a description file tag describing
SPARC version requirements for spark
based package yes that that makes a lot
of sense so the way that we work around
this well
so the way that we solve it on sparkley
are is by including the system
requirements and I might have a typo
here
requirements tag and then we say
something like spark 1.6 spark 2.0 or
2.0 X whatever so this this tack is not
was not meant to really track spark
dependencies obviously and it's also not
a system dependency per se but they the
suggestion that we got from the
Crimeline trainers is to use the system
requirements tag as a way of enumerated
which are the versions that are
supported but feedback feedback taken I
think we should definitely include tag
itself in in or a way of the for a
sparkly or extension to proactively tell
us what what's the supported version
[Music]